veamos si podemos comprender la
estructura de un fondo de cobertura y
veremos cómo funcionan las comisiones
gerenciales y de rendimiento la mayoría
de los fondos de cobertura se establecen
como sociedades limitadas este es el
fondo de cobertura establecido por [ __ ]
fondo de capital de pitt uno quizás en
el futuro cree los fondos de capital dos
y tres y pudo recabar 100 millones de
dólares el 10% de esos 100 millones o 10
millones vienen de él o mejor dicho
vienen de la gerencia de capital de pitt
que es una sociedad de responsabilidad
limitada y este inicia como el socio
general de este fondo puede resultarles
confuso pero se trata de dos compañías
separadas la gerencia de capital es la
que maneja los bienes de la otra
compañía y a cambio recibe una comisión
gerencial y también podría recibir una
comisión o gratificación por desempeño
de las que hablaremos en un momento [ __ ]
podría ser dueño de toda esta compañía
gerencia de capital de pitt y tener
cuatro o cinco empleados la forma de
trabajar de las sociedades limitadas es
similar a las acciones
no se les llaman así alguien que
contribuyó con 30 millones de dólares a
estos 100 millones recibirá el 30 por
ciento de interés de socio limitado a
quien contribuyó con el 10 por ciento
tendrá 10 millones de estos intereses
digamos que a pitt le va bastante bien y
la inversión crece antes de que tome su
comisión gerencial el fondo creció a 20
millones es decir 20 por ciento de
crecimiento neto aún sin pagar
comisiones gerenciales ni de rendimiento
lo que pita recibirá para él y su puñado
de empleados de la gerencia de capital
de pitt será en primer lugar la comisión
gerencial que se tomará del promedio del
valor neto de los bienes aquí haremos
las cuentas mensuales generales sin
entrar en detalle de la contabilidad si
[ __ ] hace esto de manera directa o
lineal más o menos el promedio anual del
valor neto de los bienes será de 110
millones por lo que su compañía recibirá
la comisión gerencial del 2 por ciento y
el 20 por ciento de comisión o
gratificación por rendimiento así que si
el promedio del valor neto de los bienes
es de 110 millones lo multiplicamos por
2% lo que significa que recibirá
2.2 millones de comisión gerencial que
le servirán para pagar los sueldos de él
y sus empleados pagar la renta compra
del equipo necesario para su trabajo de
administrar el fondo y esto tenemos que
restarlo del dinero del fondo por lo que
en lugar de tener 120 millones vamos a
tener 117.8 millones y además tenemos
que calcular la comisión por rendimiento
en este caso después de la comisión
gerencial se tienen 17.8 millones de
ganancia y de esta ganancia pitt va a
obtener el 20 por ciento de comisión o
gratificación de desempeño al menos la
empresa que administra el fondo así que
esto lo multiplicamos por el 20%
y nos va a dar 3 puntos 56 millones que
también van a la gerencia de capital de
pitt lo que no está mal recibe casi 6
millones de dólares que irán a él ya sus
empleados si alguien se desempeña bien
puede ser un negocio bastante rentable
la dinámica aquí es que estos fondos
tienden a ser abiertos o son similares a
los fondos mutualistas abiertos aunque
no pueden ser públicos son privados no
pueden tomar dinero del público ni
pueden promoverse y no tienen que
registrarse con la secretaria de
comercio cuando me refiero cuando digo
que tienen que ser abiertos me refiero a
que en ciertos momentos en el tiempo los
inversionistas pueden retirar o ingresar
inversiones digamos que al final del año
a los 117.8 millones hay que restar los
tres puntos 56 millones de la comisión
por rendimiento y nos va a quedar vamos
a usar la calculadora 117.8 menos 3.56
nos queda 114 punto 24 aunque es posible
que no retire la comisión y la vuelva a
invertir para aumentar
su participación en este fondo pero
imaginemos que al final de este periodo
los inversionistas tienen la oportunidad
de retirar su inversión o sus intereses
imaginemos que uno de los inversionistas
que aportó el 30 por ciento dice ok este
fue un muy buen año y quiero retirar un
10% de mis intereses así que en lugar
del 30 por ciento va a quedar con 20 por
ciento en el fondo y sacará el 10 por
ciento que es de 11.400 24 millones y al
fondo se va a decrementar en la misma
cantidad así que en estos periodos
particulares las personas pueden retirar
su inversión o sus intereses usualmente
es a fin de mes o cada trimestre o al
final del año en nuestro ejemplo el
fondo quedará de 114 punto 24 - 11.400
nos va a quedar 102.800 16 millones y al
mismo tiempo otras personas también
podrían querer retirar o también
contribuir o invertir más dinero en el
fondo así que no es un fondo cerrado en
el que las personas una vez que ingresan
su capital no lo pueden retirar o
agregar más así pues en los fondos de
cobertura en ciertos periodos se puede
retirar o agregar más capital